that was fascinating to be able to
create objects from from nothing and
being able to feel that you're in there
and really experience those new spaces
and uh and be really creative in that
and we I mean I really wanted to make
that uh type of experience available for
as many people as possible and you know
from there it kind of evolved to okay
what kind of Technology are available to
make sure that the machine can really
understand what people want to do
actually welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with Eric creslow the CEO of
mint since 2018 where he brought
Innovation to Market and now scaling it
internationally prior to Manti
co-founded soft kinetic inventor of 3D
depth sensors and human tracking
algorithms soft kinetic has been
acquired by Sony in 2015 before soft
kinetic Eric co-founded 72 DPI an
Innovative CGI web and entertainment
company in the early 2000s
Eric cressler welcomed to 20 minute
leaders all the way from Brussels thank
you so much for being here how are you
I'm I'm great thanks thanks for hosting
me it's phenomenal to have you here Eric
because you're working on on something
really really important and you're a
Serial entrepreneur you have a quite a
quite extensive experience one of your
companies soft kinetic sold to a Sony in
2015 looking at 3D Vision and you
continued along the same similar to path
in this industry but leveraging vision
and for for different use cases and
today doing something you know you're
truly important you know preventing
Falls of elderly in hospital nursing
homes and service flats and so I'm
really excited to unpack both your
your interest and and passion for this
world of vision in 3D but then you know
putting it to use in the different use
cases like what you're doing today with
with mint medical intelligent
Technologies and so thank you again for
being here Eric
um tell me a little bit about your
relationship with 3D Vision how did this
whole thing come about well uh I think
it's really coming from my background as
an architect because that's what I've
been studying uh and I've always been
fascinated by 3D simulations
right and so that's kind of a Natural
Evolution to go from there to
um
being interested by technologies that
can actually see in 3d and and have a
Machines of capable of understanding uh
what's the environment what's happening
what are people doing and stuff like
that so I think it's coming it's coming
really from there and from my uh passion
for new technologies
do you remember when it started your
your Keen interest specifically and in
3D you know because there's a lot of
different technologies that you can you
can spend time on why specifically this
well so again uh coming from my um
architect background yeah uh you know
I've been working a lot in the that was
the beginning like in the early 2000s
we're gonna have 3D simulations you know
um CG
um pretty modeling
um and uh you know that that was
fascinating to be able to create objects
from from nothing and being able to feel
that you're in there and really
experience those new spaces and uh uh
and be really creative in that and we I
mean I really wanted to make that uh
type of experience available for as many
people as possible and you know from
there it kind of evolved to
um okay what kind of Technology are
available to make sure that the machine
can really understand what people wants
to do actually yeah so that's the other
way around right to make it really
natural and so we started with my
colleagues and co-founders to work on
Technologies capable of understanding
what people are doing actually in a very
natural way
and so that's where we we've been
working with the new technology sensors
softwares and uh uh you know we created
soft kinetic at that time uh focusing on
entertainment mainly at the beginning
um you probably know you probably know
you know all the gesture based gaming
that came out a few um already like 10
years ago or something or so
um and so you know uh that's really
coming from there
and So Soft kinetic tell me a little bit
about soft kinetic with you know with
the Sony and then what what what was
sort of the vision behind this company
and just a little bit about that Journey
before we transition to to preventing uh
Falls for elderly right yeah so it
really began with the that uh passion
for
providing new experiences to people
uh merely first mainly for entertainment
reasons
um and so we of course we uh we worked
with a a lot of entertainment companies
like like Sony or but also Microsoft and
uh and all the video game studios that
you that you may know uh and then we um
we we we worked on a lot of different
use cases not only entertainment but uh
also most brawling broader computer
vision for uh industry uh you know for
more B2B applications professional
applications
um and so we we grew the company really
based on developing new sensors
Technologies really a new type of image
sensors and and a lot of uh software for
human tracking and human behavior
analysis in many different directions
including uh you know for automative
applications like safety in the the
cabinet of the car understanding if
people are distracted falling asleep
focused on the road you know stuff like
that
but also working on adding 3D sensing to
mobile applications that you can now
find in the in iPhones for instance you
know uh you've got the the pretty
perception in the in iPhones and the
face recognition and the
um you know
all of those use case where it's really
important to understand what people are
doing and you know their deep their
behaviors
and so we were really like a tech
company and uh working in a lot of
different
um
type of of markets and so you know came
the time where we had a really good
development with a couple of companies
including Sony so that was Natural
Evolution for soft kinetic interesting
and so as you
as you now
transition with me to to Mint what
happened you know over the last few
years that led to to the involvement of
men because also this the problem space
that you're tackling it's a it's quite
an interesting one and I'm curious as to
both uh you know why personally you you
went on this journey but then how did
you conceive of leveraging you know
technologies that you've been a part of
and you've been innovating with that are
going to be able to make a significant
impact as a part of this as a part of
this journey
well actually the really the the ID
came from one of my co-founders of
kinetic actually had a like a family uh
issue you know with the his grandmother
following and uh being on the floor for
a very long time and uh which uh ended
badly and so he had the idea okay with
that treated sensing and a gesture and
human behavior software we have we could
have avoid avoided that situation
and so that that was my read my my
co-founder who who said okay let's uh
let's do something else we have a great
technology let's uh let's try to uh uh
make it a product specifically for for
detection for prevention for all the
people
um and I thought okay totally makes
sense uh and I really wanted to start
the new a new company
um with the focus and um let's say uh
a product which can be used by a lot of
different people not only like
entertainment or you know being
integrated in more complex devices such
cars or mobile device but really that's
something that we can build from A to Z
and that we can sell or sell and make
sure that it's properly used by
um you know the seniors and really
helping them in having a better life and
uh you know more independent life
yeah I love that okay so so now take me
a little bit through immense Journey so
from inception to today what what what's
happened what did you discover what is
the you know the interesting is the
technology and where you are today
well so it really started as a
black garage work with
um another co-founder the our CTO Frank
Casello today who was really excited by
the ID and had a lot of experience in
computer vision as well in electronic
and um and um uh everything related to a
cloud cloud infrastructure and you know
iot and with the tibo my other
co-founder here they started really
trying out proof Concepts in their
garage talking with the the healthcare
professionals geriatricians nurses
um
therapists you know to really understand
if that kind of Technology could be
really useful and deployed in hospitals
and nursing homes and they found on that
yes the there was a lot of traction so
and that that's where actually I joined
the the team
um and really bringing that that
experience of taking like an ID a
nascent technology
turning that into a real product and and
really starting a real business out of
that
um and so that that's what we did since
uh like 2018 when I joined
um we had you know the we first we
finalized a real proof a real product uh
not only a proof concept that that was
really important and you know we had
what was the first product that you
created to validate and to provide value
yeah uh so that's the the famous MVP the
minimum viable product you know so that
now the look was not really nice but
that was doing the job like uh the the
first sensors were really bulky in um
and coming from uh in this Trail uh
market so but uh we
uh we wanted really to have it
working and and prove the use case
within the real professional environment
so we worked with a couple of University
Hospitals to to test that out with their
collaboration that was really important
to understand how people actually are
reacting to the technology and how
accurate it can be
so that was that was really the work
from the beginning of the company up to
uh 2018
19 something like that and then uh we
turned that into a real product
I loved it okay so that then the initial
you know installments of the product
what was that experience like so you're
working with hospitals you're you have
an MVP what was you know what was the
process of actually implementing one of
those products in the field
and observing the way that it works
well that requires actually a real
involvement from the partner so the
hospitals
um because we're really focused on
having a product in the service that is
uh fully useful for healthcare
professionals which is not a gadget
which is not just a
something that we believe is going to
help people but no our philosophy is
really that uh to be efficient for
patients we first need to be efficient
for uh Healthcare professional
because they are the ones who are going
to use the yeah the solution so then it
first need to be adopted by them so that
that's really where we focused our our
effort first and so that that meant a
lot of involvement from from the teams
there
um and so from there really it was
finalizing the uh uh the the product and
the you know after that there's really
about optimization making sure it's easy
to use it's it's not expensive
product development you know how do you
how do you measure the success of a
product like this you know in terms of a
partner and how and and what was your
success Matrix the same as theirs in
other words how do you how did you
define with your partners what is
successful pilot would be and then I
wanted to talk a little bit about
scaling
okay sure so I think I mean first and
foremost what's the most important is
that it really helps patients right
so that means that the the the
technology needs to be Rock Solid in
terms of uh detection rates and and no
what we call you know the sensitivity
and the specificity of a device making
sure that it depicts what it needs to
detect and not triggering false alarms
so that that's really number one
um
and adoption rate of the users as I
already explained that that's number two
um
well and there you know we we have
statistics about how uh people are using
or you know the the nurses and the
caregivers are using the uh the device
and the interface and what type of
information they are looking at and so
we we also worked a lot with the that
type of metrics you know um uh usability
usage you know reading it globally uh
user experience uh quality and
um so when you talk about were there
actual you know Falls or things that you
were able to to predict or prevent
through the technology that were sort of
aha moments as you depleted initially
how you were mentioning sort of the
specificity and and you want to optimize
for for being able to catch those
moments what what was there a moment
like that that proved okay this is
actually working and we can now deploy
this at scale
right yeah uh exactly actually there
were two
two really uh key findings
um first is that we discovered that more
than half of the falls were not reported
in the hospitals really
um foreign
for multiple reasons good reasons and
bad reasons good reasons that uh you
know people are just falling and
standing back up alone
so nobody knows and they are not people
are not explaining because you know they
don't want to they don't want to talk
about it
or Falls that are fully not
um notified or um noticed by by the
nurses because you know
um the uh the amount of nurses in the
hospitals nursing home are pretty low
right there's a big challenge for uh the
care institution right now it's a
recruiting the the there is no in
Harrison anymore so that's another
reason the reasons that uh you know it's
it's kind of a manual
uh work for nurses to report all that
and that's a lot of time and of work uh
and uh sometimes they don't have they
don't have the time or they consider
that the forward was not that important
so they don't do it so that means that
the the there was a lack a huge lack of
information yeah and that's really uh
the number one
uh information that uh caregiver needs
is to know what what what's happening
right of course yeah before we do that
that's the key that's one of the key
thing the second thing that we
discovered is that actually caregivers
and nurses that never see a full they
don't know where the fall is which is
normal I mean
yeah so there was a huge lack of
information
and that's one of of the added value of
our solutions that it gives actually a
lot of information about what happened
how did it happen we can really analyze
the situation before after and that
brings a lot of added value for both
nursing and the patient
interesting so let's talk about scale so
as we you know your awesome technology
it works deployed gives value how do you
then you know as a sort of an
entrepreneur now how do you take it at
scale what does that mean in terms of
the organization what does it mean in
terms of the product what does it mean
in terms of your your the time you're
spending on strategy versus product
development that's really interesting
yeah so uh indeed that's very
interesting so since the the Inception
of the the company and when I joined our
goal was really to
put everything in place to be able to
scale
so and you mentioned exactly uh the
three important point
the product needs to be uh taught for
Skilling the business model need to be
taught for Skilling and your
organization
the the three of them are really key so
uh since the beginning we we uh we
worked on
the product and You by using the right
technology to be to be able to scale
very fast so you know and everything
related to iot Cloud infrastructure that
that's really mature mature technology
right now so our product is really meant
to be super easy to deploy anywhere on
the planet as long I mean as long as you
give a connectivity right
um
and you know we are using a lot of AI as
well so we can manage a tremendous
amount of data
um that's really on the the product side
in terms of uh business model and
organization we also uh
developed and deployed uh the easiest
business model you can think about which
is subscription right so you super easy
just subscribe to the service and uh and
you get uh you get your service up and
running in no time and in terms of
organization we also focused on making
sure we can operate anywhere on the
planet from from our office here so and
and that I must say the the pandemic
Health test a little bit because
everyone started to be a
more comfortable with the working
remotely instead of being on site and
there was a physical machines all the
time so I think we we're really fully
know
um set up to uh to scale pretty fast and
that that's actually what's happening
around from the customer's perspective
the willingness for adoption the need is
that something you feel that the market
is ready it's ripe for it do you feel
that it requires a lot of explaining
explanations and selling or is it
something that's pretty smooth sailing
in terms of the implementation
right so actually it's a it's a both
good and still difficult of course and
um well again the pandemic really helped
everyone to understand that there is a
mandatory need for remote Solutions or
remote monitoring
uh being able to be much more agile in
terms of adopting new technologies
uh well you know traditionally uh
Healthcare environment are are pretty
prudent before adopting new technologies
but you know here the pandemic helped in
a sense
um
the shortage of
caregiver personal and the nurses
personally
that also already helped
I mean we we're answering that that
challenge by with new technologies that
really helps the the the the nursing
teams
well so yes uh there is a very good
momentum uh for adopting more easily
that kind of Technology what do you
enjoy most about this journey if you're
looking at you know the last four years
and where you're headed what really is
it that you
the most but I think that there are
really two things first and then really
that that's what really drives everyone
here at mint is when we we get a phone
call or an email from nurses or patients
saying okay guys you really helped uh
without you that person will probably
not be in that situation right now
um I mean that's really the
the the driver for everyone here and you
know I'm personally not coming from the
medical world so I kind of discovered
that and um you know nurses are really
uh Heroes so if I may say so that's
really a tough tough job and uh every
caregiver you know you see it firsthand
now you can see it yeah yeah
um so that's really driver the second
driver for me personally is really
probably coming from my architect
background as well is ready to go from
like an ID on paper to
um something which is real uh that
people are really using and enjoying
uh as a when you are building a house or
or any any kind of building it's first a
sketch on the paper and then you really
have people
living in it and enjoying what you
imagine I love it uh Eric thank you so
much for for your time for the awesome
work that you're doing
um it's very meaningful and I love the
interaction of the way that you're
implementing these Technologies into you
know real needs and real places and
actually providing value and it sounds
like it's a starting from the garage to
the MVP to scaling and with covert in
between sounds like a really healthy
Journey so thank you very much for
taking this time to share with me and
share with me the story and I can't wait
to to see mint adopted in in as many
rooms as possible to to help elderly so
thank you very much
thank you thank you Michael
[Music]